yo you said something yesterday about
the voting [ __ ]
yeah okay so yeah
from what i read on your story you would
pretty much said i'm gonna just go out
here and vote just to show y'all
don't matter that is fluke that is fluke
or something to that point
so can you please elaborate on that but
then i also posted after which i will
elaborate on that but then i'll suppose
that i was joking and i wasn't going to
vote
um okay you wait you didn't vote no oh
okay
why not okay so let's let's get in there
yeah let's go let's go
so i have posted that let me take these
like mentos um
because they keep jingling and [ __ ]
and it's 20 20 and we don't be in my
immediate training [ __ ] man
we're doing what we want to do but um
so i have posted oh like how we're
taking blint's
mid interview this is so good it's
awesome um
so i posted yo i'm going to go vote just
to show you
how fluke get it that is just flute and
for like 30 minutes i
almost convinced myself that i was and i
was like what are you doing
cut it out and then i posted that i
wasn't going to vote and
um that i'm not going to
participate and encourage my followers
that y'all don't have to be
bullied into participating in something
that isn't true to you
if you do not connect if you do not i'm
talking about on the presidential status
if you want to go and vote
for the lower level voting city voters
councils
things of that nature different like
props and laws
100 but i'm talking about a presidential
level which everyone was campaigning for
that's what i'm talking about but on
that same ballot is all the local [ __ ]
100
that affects a lot of [ __ ] 100 so
if you're going but i'm speaking about
you because if you go and vote
so when you're saying if i'm not voting
correctly correct me
if you go and vote you don't have to
vote
yeah president exactly that's what
that's what i'm saying you don't have to
yeah you can leave whatever on that
ballot empty that you don't want to vote
on my point
so if it's if you feel inspired to go
out and vote for
anything that you feel inspired for
which was my part of my post
and then by all means go vote but you
also have the right especially
us color people mom illinois anybody
there are american africans in this
country you 100 have the right to
not vote just as much you have the right
to vote you know what i mean especially
if
neither one of these people resonate
with you so let me ask you a question
though dude i don't [ __ ] with trump or
biden neither do i but i really don't
[ __ ] with trump
yeah right so but let me ask you this
though but like
if you think about okay let's say
hypothetically speaking we rewind how
long has we been recreational out here
it's been like
almost 10 years right no recreational
it's probably been like
a little over two years uh yeah 2016's
yeah yeah yeah exactly where it's just
like smoke outside
so so if you think about it right
even if you go before before medicinal
right people had to go out and vote for
that
to happen yeah right and so there's a
lot of people who
might be in jail right now had that not
gotten passed
we can't walk like if you go i mean you
know this you've been on the road
100 you can't walk around louisville
kentucky with weed the way you can walk
around
l.a my first time ever going to jail my
only time i've ever been to jail just to
piggyback was in atlanta for
literally a point zero zero one a wheat
i can't even grab as much wheat out of
here that i had
so what i'm saying is those those things
like actually affect people we know
100 right and i do think too there's
another conversation to be had about the
president [ __ ]
but i think if you have any sort of
platform if you choose not to vote
that's on you but i just don't think
it's very
i don't think you have to promote not
voting
right because even if you like i i
i agree with you about the presidential
[ __ ] neither candidate was inspiring
one of them though is hitler i've seen
no because i've seen you on instagram
talk like like having run-ins with trump
supporters
yeah and [ __ ] like that one of them is
is galvanizing that energy yeah and one
of them is just a piece of [ __ ]
right so one of them is a a flaming pile
of dog [ __ ] on your front porch and one
of them is just some regular dogs
like the flaming pile of dog [ __ ] could
light your whole house on fire
right the other pile of dog [ __ ] is just
dog [ __ ] you could just clean it up and
you know it might not ruin your entire
house that's a bar
you feel me better bar up right now okay
so
with the president though comes so many
other things like supreme court justice
for example they just got this catholic
[ __ ] up in there
who trump's trying to bring in no no
it's done okay yeah they pushed her
through
okay so now because of that
there might not be a abortion might get
taken off of the [ __ ]
roe versus wade might get overturned
yeah so while you might not [ __ ] with
joe biden
because i don't [ __ ] with joe biden you
can dig up the tweets on me [ __ ] on
that man
i don't [ __ ] with your body yeah i don't
[ __ ] with kamala harris for the record
yeah i don't [ __ ] with her but
if they get elected it means that a
supreme court justice that won't
overturn abortion rights
or overturn gay marriage it's like
i hear you but i'm like look i'm a
bernie sanders [ __ ] right
i was rocking with bernie big bad bird
bernie and andrew yang
neither of them [ __ ] made it
through and i i'm
really i have a lot of disdain for the
dnc i think it's very corrupt
i think like the stuff you're saying
they feel very
uh entitled to black people's votes to
hispanic people's votes
yeah and they just take it for granted
and then they do this really
trash ass pandering with these
celebrities like shout out to two james
love two chains but the fact on stage
by the way i think that might be the
second time he's done that's my dog
though
but what i'm saying is like i hear you
and you have every right to be like man
[ __ ] y'all
but i don't know if now's the time
if it was like just some normal
run-of-the-mill republican on the other
side
who wasn't on fire in front of your
house who could set your whole house on
fire
yeah if it was just a piece of [ __ ] and
a piece of [ __ ] well there's two
two pieces of [ __ ] here it's just really
a matter of you know
whether or not you want to sit the
election out but like [ __ ] is crazy dog
and i've seen you have interactions with
these
racist people i literally just um just
to be back i literally just drove past
some trump dude and we both like drew
down on each other he showed me he had
his gun and i showed him my mind
i'm like okay can you hear me you
weren't ready [ __ ] i'm more red too
so so those people have always existed
the only thing about trump being
president is at least now that we know
who they are
yeah like if you see somebody with a
flag hanging off the back of their car
that's another level of like i
understand if you are
i don't understand if you're a trump
supporter but if you're a silent trump
supporter and you're just like yo i'm
voting for him for tax
whatever the race racism isn't a deal
breaker whatever
right but if you're the type of
[ __ ] that's out here with flags
hanging off your truck
that tells me you're a real racist
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you kind of are about something you're
about to do you might want some smoke it
might be about a little something but
what i'm saying is
i understand how you could be uninspired
but at the same time you have to
understand that like even if you
affected
20 people not voting that's a lot of
people
yeah and i think that if you take
even just the local measures those are
the measures that really affect
our day-to-day life like
that's where you got to like i hear you
yeah
you have the right to not vote you have
the right to say i i'm just telling you
i i think that
you're a very smart dude and i
understand how you could feel like
these [ __ ] just think i'm just
supposed to vote for them because this
is who they're force-feeding me
and guess what that's how they feel
you're right these [ __ ]
really do just think like when this full
joe biden said if you don't vote if you
vote for donald trump you ain't black
that [ __ ] is insane like
the like how crazy was that i love that
the whistle for the people who are gonna
hear the podcast with no video you got
that whistle i'm gonna give you another
one but no
that was like like a bomb at the end of
it no but that was exactly what you were
talking about
the fact that he had the audacity to say
that is like bruh
bro i'm gonna tell you like first off
i can't say that i disagree with what
you're saying
like you know what i mean um
by the way california's going blue
either way whether you vote or not but
no none of the matter
continue regardless like i'm talking
about california
like but that's not that that's neither
here nor there true that's neither here
nor there
um
just to just to hit on the the dog [ __ ]
that's burning
in front of the the doorway first
just real quick too for me personally
and i believe for many
colored people that have grew up it just
sounds really bad when you say colored
people yeah if not not as bad as if i
said it you don't no you already know i
hear you i know
you're pushing me you could say you
could say melano's you can say black to
me
saying black is worse than colored
that's fair i don't like because you're
not black
yeah this is black right this is [ __ ]
black yeah that [ __ ] is not tight i'm
very like bronze
real looking i'm just i'm what they
described to jesus in the bible
you know what i'm saying literally but
so black ain't it but so
i don't know that's fair you know what i
mean um
i feel like the
burning [ __ ] has been in the front of
like literally every time i walk outside
of my door the burning shit's there bro
i don't
and this is not to like just try to like
you know say but it's just literally my
reality
it's equivalent to like
being
being to [ __ ] it i'll use it in regular
terms because i always
always use the analogy of like a castle
being taken and put into a castle and
putting at the bottom of the dungeon and
having to vote for who's at the top of
the couch [ __ ] that
right imagine you artists or you um
um personalities you bosses you [ __ ]
because you're not a pro you you got
your own [ __ ] studio company [ __ ]
fathers husbands
imagine you all being
as an artist being taken to underscore
imagine interscope taking me
my rights everything and owning me
and they're like yo you got to do what
the [ __ ] we say you like you know what i
mean
we own you you're in interscope right
period this is what the [ __ ] it is
and you want me to vote for who's like
the president of this company
i'm not voting for [ __ ] y'all y'all owe
me regardless i'm here regardless that's
literally my
that's literally my perspective on
voting when you are a melanoid when
you're american african in this country
because the way i feel is this
neither of them and it's not hard the
same way you can reach out to little
pump because he's on
instagram making a hurrah hurrah about
how he [ __ ] with trump
so you feel the need to reach out to him
and bring him up for a [ __ ] rally
because he's made that much noise on
instagram do you know how much noise our
people have been making for reparations
on instagram alone
right i think [ __ ] ain't saying [ __ ]
about it [ __ ] y'all
i don't i'm not so for me what one thing
if you pay attention to me and you pay
attention to
the things that i truly post and you're
like literally paying attention
you see that i never press my view on
anything
i'm not a christian my family my mother
i'm a full-fledged christian but my
mother's a full-fledged christian i
fully believe in the christian faith i'm
just not a christian
right you know what i'm saying but
that's not why i'm rocking i
rock go move how you move i never push
for people to do what i do
look do your history do your research
and then go with what
resonates with your god feeling